and pardon my ignorance but rastafar
Rastafari that's a religion Rastafarian
yeah Rastafarian and and in uh the
Rastafarian religion like smoking weed
is part of the deal oh yeah a big big
part of this religious ceremony right
yeah yeah so so uh your dad had like
this this super healthy like everything
but like did he want you to smoke weed
no he actually caught me smoking weed
when I was
I was just living with him and my little
sister at the time I didn't have my
brothers around so I was just like bored
as [ __ ] I didn't know what to do with
myself a lot of the time because I
didn't really have friends either and he
caught me smoking weed one day I was
like smoking one of his little little
old little joints
and he was pissed and
he was just someone who got got easily
got pissed at me and my siblings about
things but I remember thinking like bro
like
how do you ex how are you gonna get mad
at me when you've been blowing weed
smoke in my face since I was a baby like
how does that make sense like yeah yeah
and that's the dreads that what the
decision to cut the dreads was that a
heavy decision because it's it's kind of
like a you know it was it was but that
was also like a year after I hadn't seen
my dad because my parents got divorced I
hadn't seen my mom in a while my mom got
custody and then at that point I was
finally able to like kind of live my own
life and be my own person you know have
friends actually like have fun with my
life and being a skateboarder and about
a year after that I remember it was just
kind of a random decision I think I was
like skating the barracks one day I was
filming a battle commander and
in the middle of filming it I was just
like dude like I just I can't do it
anymore these things are just too
[ __ ] long and they're just always in
my face how long did you grow them out
for 16 years 16 years yeah wow yeah
because the the in the in the rastafire
religion is no razors no there's like
three things that you know the way you
don't so it was your entire lifetime of
hair yeah
did you just you just got up and did it
yeah it was one night I just did it
because I just felt like it was time for
something new and sure it really was
hard to deal with those things like yeah
I mean like one or two more years and I
would have been Landing my tricks and
rolling them over wow dude that's crazy
and you cut them off on camera no not
even on camera I didn't even give a [ __ ]
I was just like ah these things have had
their had their time right so then there
was a video part where some of you had
dreads and then the dreads were gone it
was like yeah yeah like halfway through
the part the judge were gone
this is my element that was element rise
and shine that was just the video of me
right kind of like coming back it's no
secret that Johnny Knoxville and I are a
little older too old to deliver the mail
but we can still lick the stamp
and I think we look pretty good right
here this Remains the only thing you've
ever signed for selling yeah this is
only thing I've ever tried to sell
so much pressure when Steve O's filmed
everybody grab these Johnny O
skateboards while you can I'd suggest
you hurry
yeah dude